down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to
light that's also the ongoing mission of
Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in
1991 irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
preser presen in and understanding of
Islam in an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of Islam irf
also imparts dawa training to D to aptly
convey The Message of Islam Dr Zakir Nik
president of irf reaching out across
countries worldwide from America to
Europe to Africa to Asia to Australia
strives to clarify Islamic viewpoints he
dispels the many media myths and
anti-islamic prejudices propagated the
world over by anti-islamic forces irf
today is creating a change in the hearts
and minds of millions of Muslims and
non-muslims worldwide towards a proper
understanding and respect for Islam have
a question or doubt about Islam and its
teachings now you know one of the best
Resource Centers to get convincing
answers from is Islamic Research
Foundation Mumbai India for more
information
log on to our website
www.ir
f.net mam
is and always will be the last and
final prophet of
[Music]
Allah he was a
mercy unto the you
Universe peace and blessings be on
[Music]
must I'm
brothers and
sisters I am manour
sheh the host for today's
program we begin our
program with the recitation of Holy
Quran zikra n
will recite before you Surah zik
B
[Music]
Allah
for for
[Music]
[Applause]
now I call
upon rushda n she will do the Kat of
Surah DHA
[Music]
Al for
this was n
alhamdulillah
now I call
upon farik n he will present Islamic
song m u s l i m 1 billion strong all
year long pray to Allah even in Hong
Kong can never be wrong if you read the
Quran God has never been tast since they
want other be brag say that we lag but
they don't know all the power we had the
power we had the power we had so Muslim
Mo don't you ever be sad take merry
looks go read their books you'll see all
the facts that our friends overlooks
always be proud you can say it out loud
I'm proud to be down with the Muslim
crowd M you us L I am I'm so blessed to
be with them M L I am I'm so blessed to
be with them don't know about you I know
about me I'm proud to Rolling
islamically everywhere I see even on TV
people talking trash about the way I be
but what they all hate is if you get
great cuz you are the one with your
heads on straight don't ever frown with
your head looking down if you read the
Quran you're the best in the town you
all have doubts say we have no clap but
within a few years see how we've come
about come back to the scene the number
one Dean I'm proud to be down with the
Muslim m l i m I'm so blessed to be with
them m l i I'm so blessed to be with
[Applause]
them now we have rusda n
delivering a song Islamic song I Believe
In
allahum I stand in the line and pray and
zaka I pay I fast in Ramadan cuz I
believe in Allah I'm nice to my fellow
men I'm kind to my parents my elders I
respect cuz I believe in Allah watch ing
over me all things Allah can see I want
to be sure he's happy with my Deeds he
answers me in prayer when I call he's
always there he helps me through the day
yes I believe in Allah I love to hear
the Adan I love my Dean Islam I hope to
go to Makkah cuz I believe in Allah I
believe I believe I believe in Allah I
believe I believe yes I believe in
Allah
now rushda Nayak will deliver a Islamic
song talk to me about Muhammad peace be
upon him I request the audience
especially for this song please
carefully pay attention to each and
every word of this song it will
inshallah touch the strings of your
heart it would be such a pleasure to
have you come along with me I accept
your gracious offer of kindness and
Company but as we walk along young man
and as you help me with the load I have
only one request as we travel down this
road don't talk to me about Muhammad
because of him there is no peace and I
have trouble in my mind so don't talk to
me about
Muhammad and as we walk along together
we will get along just fine I have only
one request as we travel down this road
to talk to me about
Muhammad that man upsets me so so much
more than you could know I of his name a
reputation everywhere I go though his
family and his clan once knew him as an
honest man he's dividing everyone with
his claim that God is one so don't talk
to me about Muhammad and as we walk
along together we will get along just
fine I have only one request as we
travel down this road to talk to me
about Muhammad
thank you now young man you have been so
really kind your generosity and smile
are very rare to find let me give you
some advice since you have been so very
nice from mammad stay away don't heed
his words or emulate his way and don't
talk to me about Muhammad you will never
have true peace and trouble is all you
find so don't talk to me about
Muhammad now before we part and go if
it's all right just the same may I ask
you my dear young man who are you what's
your name forgive me what was that your
words were in very clear my ears are
getting old sometimes it's difficult to
hear it's truly rather fun
though I'm sure I must be wrong but I
thought I heard you say your name is
muhamad
mam
[Music]
Allah talk to me muhamad upon you I pray
for peace for you have eased my troubl
mind m talk to me Muhammad and as we
walk along this road we will get along
just fine as I travel down this road I
will get long just
fine
jaak rushda for a very impressive song
indeed now I call upon Sayad Shah
Hussein Kadri to deliver the welcome
note
welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings it's an honor and privilege
for me to welcome our world famous or
writer on universal Brotherhood and
comparative religion Dr Zakir
nyak chair person manzur shik I also
welcome the staff and crew of irf
Islamic Research Foundation
Bombay I'm gratified by the presence of
such a huge and enthusiastic crowd
waiting patiently to know about the
presence of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in World religious
scriptures I pray to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala that all doubts prevailing in
your mind regarding the topic are
cleared thank you
brothers and sisters the presence of all
of you in several thousands
here is definitely an indication to me
that you are all very eager
to listen to Dr Zakir and therefore I
shall not take much of your time in
introducing the esteemed speaker to you
I will only take a few words to tell you
about him Dr Zakir
basically a medical doctor by profession
turned around completely and came out to
serve the cause of Allah his activities
for the
past two decades have brought a
revolution in the field of dawa and to
project the correct picture of Islam in
its right perspective Dr Zakir has
traveled to several countries in the
world
mainly USA UK Canada and many other
countries of
Europe his Zeal to project the Islam in
its right
perspective has brought Laurels for him
and cleared the misconception about
Islam to many
people he resorted
to creating a new field for dawa by
studying comparative religion and he
studied many books on Islam and
comparative
religion he calls himself most humbly as
the student of Islam and comparative
religion he has also traveled to several
cities in this country to deliver his
talk and has been in the Forefront of
the dawa activities I take upon this
unique opportunity to request
him to deliver his talk on the topic
Muhammad peace be upon him in the
various World religious
scriptures
alhamdulillah wasam
my respected
elders and my dear brothers and sisters
I welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings asum
may peace mercy and blessings of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala of allmighty God be on
all of
you the topic of this evening talk
is
Muhammad peace be upon him in the
various World religious
scriptures many people have a
misconception that Islam is a new
religion which came into existence, 1400
years ago and Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon Him is the founder of this
religion in fact Islam is there since
time
immemorial since man set foot on this
Earth and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is not the founder of this religion
but he is the last and final messenger
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala of all Mighty
God which was sent for the whole of
humankind the Glorious Quran says
in chapter number 35 verse number
24 there is not a nation to whom we have
not sent a
Warner Allah says in Surah chapter
number 13 verse number
7 and to Every Nation have we sent a
guide
by name there are 25 prophets of
almighty god mentioned in the
Quran for example Adam Noah Abraham
Moses Jesus Muhammad peace be upon them
all there are no less than 25 prophets
mentioned in the Glorious Quran by name
but Allah also says in the Quran inaha
chapter number 4 verse number 164 and
Surah chapter number 40 verse number 7
we narrate to you the stories of some of
the messengers of some of the prophets
of the others we don't that means all
the prophets have not been mentioned by
name in The Glorious
Quran and our beloved Prophet Muhammad
sah wasallam said it's
ath which is mentioned in
Mishi volume number three Hadith number
5737 our beloved Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Ali wasallam said that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has sent about
124,000 prophets on the face of the
Earth but by name only 25 are mentioned
in the Quran but all the messengers that
came before the last and final messenger
Prophet muhammmad peace be upon him they
were only sent for their people and the
complete message which they brought was
only meant to be followed in totality
till a particular time period all the
messengers that came before Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him they were
only meant for a particular group of
people for example isaam Jesus Christ
peace be upon him was only sent for the
Jews for the bani Israel Allah says in
the Quran in Surah Al Imran chapter
number 3 verse number 49 that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him was sent as a
messenger to the bani Israel to the
children of
Israel the same message repeated in
Surah saf chapter number 61 verse number
6 Jesus Christ peace be upon Him says to
the bani Israel I've been sent as a
messenger to you and this same message
is even repeated in the
Bible it's mentioned in the Bible in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 10
verse number 5 and 6 Jesus Christ peace
be upon Him says he tells to his
Apostles that go ye not into the way of
the Gentiles who are the
Gentiles the
non-jews the Hindus
the Muslims go in not into the way of
the Gentiles enter not into the city of
the Stines but rather go to the lordship
of the House of
Israel the same message repeated in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 15
verse number 24 where Jesus Christ peace
be upon him himself says that I have not
been sent but to the Lost ship of the
House of Israel that means according to
the Quran and the Bible Jesus Christ CHR
peace be upon him was only sent for the
B Israel only for the Jews for the
children of Israel but Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon
him was the last and final messenger I
started my talk by quoting a verse from
the Glorious Quran from Surah chapter
number 33 verse number
40 which
says mhammad peace be upon Him is not
the father of any of you
men but he is the messenger of Allah and
he is the Seal of the prophets Allah is
all knowing full of knowledge because
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
the last and final messenger of almighty
God he was not sent only for the Muslims
or only for the Arabs Allah says in the
Quran in Surah Ambia chapter number 21
verse number
107 we have sent thee not but as a mercy
to all the worlds as a mercy to all the
creatures as a mercy to the whole of
humanity Allah repeats the message in
Sur saah chapter number 34 Verse number
28 we have send thee not but as a
universal messenger giving Glad Tidings
and warning them against sin but most of
the human beings yet do not know because
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
the last and final messenger and no
other messenger no other Prophet is
going to come after him that's the
reason he was not sent only for the
Muslims or for the Arabs he was sent for
the whole of
humankind we
Muslims because we believe that the
Glorious Quran is the word of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala is the last and final
revelation of almighty God what whatever
the Quran says we believe that's why we
also believe that Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him is the last and final
messenger and we also believe that he
was sent for the whole of
humankind but most of the
non-muslims the non-muslims in general
they do not believe that the Quran is
the word of
God that's the reason they may not agree
that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
is the last and final messenger of God
and was sent for the whole of
humanity that's the reason to convince
the
non-muslims I'm taking the help and
guidance of one of the verses of the
Quran which I consider as the master key
for dawa for conveying the message to
the non-muslims Allah says in Surah Al
Imran chapter number 3 verse number
64 come to Common terms ask between us
and you
when we are speaking with different
types of
people the best way is as the Quran says
come to Common terms as between us and
you so let us
analyze what do the various religious
World scriptures have to speak about
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him so the non-muslims if they believe
in these
scriptures which they follow if if it's
mentioned in the scriptures if they
consider
it to be the word of God then they have
to even believe in the message of these
scriptures let us first
discuss Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him in the Hindu
scriptures the Hindu scriptures can be
broadly divided into two categories the
shuis and the
smes shti means that which is
revealed which is
understood which is heard the shuti
according to the Hindu Scholars is
considered to be the word of God and
they are divided into two parts the V
and the upanishad the Sanskrit word v is
derived from the word vid which means
knowledge by
excellence and there are four types of
vs rig yaj Sam
Anda though exactly
when did these W come into existence is
not known but according to Swami Dan
sarasti who's the founder of the Arya
samage he says that the V are
1,310 million years
old but the majority of the Hindu
Scholars they say that the vade are
approximately 4,000 years old in which
part of the
world did it first
come is not known who was the person to
whom it was first given is not known in
spite of all these ambiguities it is yet
considered to be the word of God and it
is the most authentic and the most high
scriptures amongst all the Hindu
scriptures the next in Authority are the
upanishads derived from the Sanskrit
word Opa which means
near KN down sh sit sitting down near
when the pupils and students sat next to
the teacher to knowledge it's called
which means knowledge which removes
ignorance there are more than 200
upanishads but the Indian culture gives
a figure of 108 out of which some are
picked up as the principal upanishads
some have picked up 10 some 12 sh radak
Krishan has picked up 18 and written a
book the principal upanishads the next
type of scriptures are the
smis SMY means that which is remembered
it means
memory the Hindu Scholars say smritis
are scriptures written by human beings
by Ries and they are next after the shti
the shis are higher than the smithies
they're also called as dharmashastra
because they tell how a life should be
led by an individual by the community
and by the society one of the most
important
smiti is the purana purana means ancient
it talks about the stories of
dieties about the creation of the
universe about
literature and Maharishi Vas has
compiled the puranas into 18 voluminous
Parts one of the most important puranas
is called as the bhavisha pan bhavisha
means future this purana speaks about
the future and it's mentioned in
bhavisha purana Par 3 3 ADH 3 shlokas 5
to8 a Malaya will
come along with his
companions from the desert and his name
shall be Muhammad
peace be upon
him and Raja BJ will give this Mahadev
Arab a bath in the punch gar and will
welcome him with honor and address him
with reverence and say oh pride of human
kind you have created a great force to
fight against the evil people this
prophecy of
bish 3 ADH 3 shlokas 5 to8 it says that
a Malaya will come Malaya in Sanskrit
means a foreigner he will come along
with his companions talking about the
sahabas
from a maral maral in Sanskrit means a
Sandy track or a desert his name shall
be Muhammad please be upon Him Raja BJ
will address this Mahadev Arab with
reverence and say oh pride of
humankind we know that Muhammad
sallallah Al
wasallam is a pride of humankind as
Allah says in the Quran in Surah chapter
number 68 verse number four verily thou
art standeth on the highest standard of
character Allah says in Surah aab
chapter number 33 verse number 21 verily
in the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him you will find a very beautiful
pattern of
conduct he further says that he will
collect a great force to fight against
the evil people and we know that was
done by Prophet Muhammad sallallah
alaihi wasallam this prophecy refers to
to no one but Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon
him some people may say that the Raja B
mentioned in this
prophecy was present in the 11th century
500 years after Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him and was the descendant of
the 10th Generation of Raja
shahan these people they fail to realize
that like the monarchs of Egypt they
were given the title pharaohs there were
many pharaohs there was not one Pharaoh
like the kings of Rome were called as
Caesars there was not one Caesar there
were many Caesars similarly the kings of
India were given the title B so there
was not one Raja B there were many Raja
B so this
rajab is not the one they're talking
about in 11th century it is much earlier
before that 11th century further it's
mentioned in bhavisha Pana Par 3 K 3 ad
3 shlokas
10-27 the land of the
malas has been spoiled those the enemy
who killed earlier now he's been sent by
a more powerful enemy I will send a man
by the name
Muhammad peace be upon Him to guide
these people to the straight path oh
Raja B you need not go to the land of
the pachas because I through my kindness
will purify you where you are then a man
with an angel disposition comes to Raja
and tells him that Arya D will prevail
in this world I have been sent by ishwar
patma my follower shall be
circumcised who doesn't have a tail on
the
head who will grow a beard who will
create a revolution who will give the
call for prayer he will eat all lawful
things he will eat all sorts of animals
but will not eat the Flesh of swine he
will not be purified by herbs and shrubs
but will be purified by Warfare he will
be called as musulman this prophecy
refers to No One But the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam it says that my follower shall
be a person who circumcised and we know
the Muslims are circumcised he will not
have a tail on the head that's a shandy
or a Chui he will grow a beard he will
create a revolution he will give the
call for prayer that talking about the
Adan like Muslims give he will eat all
lawful things he will eat all sorts of
animal but will not eat the Flesh of
swine and Allah says in the Quran in no
less than four different places in Surah
Bak chapter number 2 verse number 173
Surah ma chter number 5 verse number 3
Surah Anam chter number 6 verse number
145 and Surah chter number 16 verse
number5 for for you for food are dead
meat blood the Flesh of swine and any
food on which any name besides Allah's
name is taken so because the Quran says
in no less than four different places
that flesh of swine is prohibited we
Muslims don't eat
poke the prophecy further says they will
not be purified by herbs and shs but
will be purified by W and they will be
called as musulman this prophecy clearly
indicates about the coming of the last
and final messenger Prophet Muhammad
Salli wasallam it's further mentioned in
bhavisha purana 3 K one ADH 3 shlokas
21-23 it says that the seven sacred
cities of Kashi have been filled with
corruption and
rakas in the land of the Malaya the
followers of the Malaya DH are good
people all good qualities are found in
them
and in this country we find all sorts of
vices oh Rishi glorify the name of the
Lord here too it is talking about
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
and his
followers Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is also prophesized in The
Vedas he is prophesized in Atara book
number 20 himym number
127 Mantra number 1 to4 it is called as
Kap suas
up means hidden gland in the abdomin
that means the meaning of these verses
are hidden and you'll come to know about
it later on Kap also means Free From
Misery also means peace similar to Islam
it's also related to the Center of the
Earth and we know Makkah is the center
of the earth and Allah says in the Quran
in Surah Al Imran 3:96 that the first
place of worship was Baka which is
another from
makah time will not permit me to go
through all the 14 mantras I'll just
briefly speak about the first four
mantras at book number 20 himym number
127 Mantra number one says he is
Nara he is Kama who has been protected
from 6,90 enemies man number two says he
is a camel riding Rishi man number three
says he is mamar Rishi Mantra number
four says he is v r the first Mantra
says he is narash shansa Nar in Sanskrit
means a human being or a man shansa
means
pra praiseworthy a man who is
praiseworthy which is exactly the
translation of the Arabic word Muhammad
which was the name of the last and final
messenger Muhammad Sall wasallam it
further says he is
one of the meaning of k is a prince of
peace and a beloved Prophet mammi
wasallam was a prince of peace the other
meaning is an immigrant and we know
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
migrated from Makkah to Madina and he
was an
immigrant it further says he will be
protected from 6,090 enemies and we know
the population of macah that was against
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
was approximately 60,000
manra number two says he will be a camel
riding Rishi no Indian Rishi or a
Brahman will ever ride a camel because
riding a camel is prohibited for a
Brahman it's mentioned in Manus smiti
chapter number 11 verse number 202 that
a Brahman will not ride a camel or an
ass therefore it has to be a prophet who
is a
foreigner third Mantra says his mamar
Rishi or Mahar Rishi Mama
some vers say Muhammad some say great
Rishi Mantra number four says he's RAB
RAB means one who praises which is the
meaning of the other name of prophet mm
sallu Al wasallam one who praises in
Arabic is called as Ahmed which was the
other name of prophet Muhammad Salli
wasallam Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam is also prophesized in book
number 20 him number 21 manra number six
it says it's speaks about the Battle of
aab the battle of Ali and it says
that he will be
protected from 10,000 enemies and he
will win the battle without fighting
it he will be
aaru now Karu in Sanskrit means a person
who praises in Arabic it means Ahmed
which is another name for Muhammad
sallallah Al wasallam it says he will
win the battle without fighting it
talking about the Battle of azah
which was one without fighting it and we
know the approximate population the
enemies at that time were
10,000 it further says in Atara book
number 20 hymn number 21 Mantra number 7
that almighty God will overthrow 20
Kings and he will protect the aandu from
6,099 enemies aandu in Sanskrit means an
orphan the other meaning of Abu means
praiseworthy which is the translation of
Muhammad into English peace be upon him
so Abu in Sanskrit if you translate to
Arabic means Muhammad sah
wasallam it says that almighty God will
overthrow 20 Kings and we know that
there were approximately 20
Chieftains in Makkah at the time of m s
wasallam Andi wasallam W all of them and
the enemies against the prophet M
wasallam at that time was approximately
60,000 the same prophecy is also
repeated in rig book number one himym
number 53 Mantra number n but the
Sanskrit word used is suama sushama also
means one who is praiseworthy which is
the meaning of Muhammad sallallahu Al
wasallam and Prophet M Salli wasallam is
also
prophesied in Anni Mantra number 64 and
it says that this Rishi he will not
drink the milk of his mother he will not
be breastfed by his mother and we know
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
was not breastfed by his own
mother and B may Allah pleas with her
she was the one who breathed MMI
wasallam Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam is also prophesies as Ahmed one
who praises in several
places in utar Mantra number
1,500 in Indra chapter number two Mantra
number 152 in yaj chapter number 31
verse number 18 in rig book number8 him
number six manra number 10 Ina book
number eight himn number five man number
16 Ina book number 20 himn number 126
month number 14 Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam besides being
prophesized as Ahmed is even prophesized
in several places as
naranga as I mentioned earlier narash
shansa is derived from Nar which means a
human being or a man and shansa comes
from the word prashansa which means
praise a man who is
praiseworthy Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
Ali wasallam is prophesized by name as
Muhammad S wasallam as Nara in several
places in Hindu scriptures in rade book
number one him number 13 man number
three in rig book number one himn number
18 month number n in rade book number
one himn number 106 mon number four in
rig book number one himm number one 42
month number three in rade book number
two himm number three month number two
in rade book number five himn number
five month number two in rig book number
seven himym number two month number two
in rig book number 10 him number 64 man
number three rig book number 10 him
number 182 man number two yaj chapter
number 20 verse number 37 yaj chapter
number 20 verse number 57 J chapter
number 21 verse number 31 chapter number
21 verse number 55 yaj chapter number 28
verse number 2 y chapter number 28 verse
number 19 y chapter number 28 verse
number 42 you can go on only giving
references of the Hindu scriptures where
Prophet Muhammad sallah am is mentioned
by
name time does not permit us you can
give a lecture for a full day only on
muhamad sallah Alam Hindu scriptures due
to limitation of time I'll just mention
one more prophecy about Muhammad
sallallah Alam Hindu scriptures that is
about K it's mentioned in bhagat
Pana K 12 ad
2 shlokas 18 to
20 it says that in the house of Vishnu
Yas the noble sold
Brahman the chief of the village of
sambala will be
born
Ki he will be given Superior qualities
and will be given eight Supernatural
qualities he will ride a white horse and
carry the sword in the right hand it's
further mentioned bhagat Pana K one ad
month number 25 in kalyug when kings
will be like robbers in kalyug when
kings will be like robbers in the house
of Vishnu Yas will be born
Ki he's even prophesized in Kip
purana chapter number
two Mantra number four it says that in
the house of Vishnu Yas the noble sold
Brahman the chief of the village of
sambala will be born K it's mentioned Ki
purana chapter number two mon number
five he will be helped by four
companions to fight the evil people it's
mentioned Kip purana chapter number two
mon number seven he'll be held by the
deas or the angels in the battlefield
it's mentioned in kipana chapter number
2 verse number 11 he'll be born in the
house of Vishnu Yas in the womb of
sumiti it's mentioned Kip purana chapter
number two verse number 15 he'll be born
on the 12th day of the month of madav in
short all these verses of the Hindu
scriptures they speak about the
kar I'll just mention in brief the few
points which is prophesized in the
scripture Point number one his father's
name will be Vishnu Yas Vishnu means god
Yas means the servant it means the
servant of God if you translate to
Arabic it means Abdullah which was the
name of the father of prophet mham Salli
wasallam the mother's name will be sumti
sumti in Sanskrit means Serenity calm
peace in Arabic it means am which was
the name of the mother of prophet
Muhammad Salli
wasallam it says he will be born in the
village of sambala sambala
means a place of Serenity and peace and
we know Makkah was called as Dar am
means the house of peace
and Prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam was born in
Makkah it further says he'll be born In
The House of the chief of the village of
sambala and we know mammad sallallah Ali
wasallam was born in the house of the
chief of Makkah it further says he'll be
born on the 12th day of the month of mad
and we know Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam was born on the 12th date of
RAB it further says that he will be the
last Rishi the last prophet the antim
Rishi and we know it's mentioned in the
Quran in Sur
33 ver number
40 Muhammad Sall Ali wasallam is not the
father of any of you men but he is the
messenger of Allah and is the Seal of
the prophets Allah is all knowing and
full of knowledge so the Quran says that
he will be the last messenger Prophet
Muhammad wasallam it further says that
this Rishi this
he will get the knowledge the
enlightenment the first one at night
time in a cave and then he will go
towards north and come back we know
mammad sallallahu Ali wasallam the first
wahi he got was a night time
in and the Quran says inan 44 vers
number 2 and 3 as well as 97 verse
number one which
says verily we have revealed the Quran
in the night of power
and we know mammad sallallah Ali
wasallam migrated to Madina which was in
the north direction of Makkah and then
he came back to Makkah it further says
he will be given extremely good
qualities it further says he will be
given eight Supernatural qualities the
eight mentioned in the Hindu scriptures
is wisdom self-control reveal knowledge
respected lineage Valor measured
speech gratefulness and utmost charity
all these eight qualities alhamdulillah
are found in the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad Sall
wasallam it further says that he will be
a messenger for the whole of humankind
as Allah says in Surah Sabah chapter
number 34 Verse number
28 we have sent thee not but as a
universal messenger giving Glad Tidings
and warning them against sin but most of
the human beings yet do not know it
further says that he will be given a
white horse and we know mam sallah Ali
wasallam was given the B by which he did
the Mir It also says that he will ride a
horse carrying the sword in the right
hand and we know mad Sall wasallam even
took part in the battle most of which
were in self-defense he actively took
part and even had the sword in the right
hand the prophecy further says he will
guide the ignorant people to the
straight path and We Know M wasallam
guided the Arabs those days were called
as the days of ignorance and Muhammad
sallu Ali wasallam with the help of
Allah subhana wa tala with the help of
the Quran he guided the Arabs from
Darkness to light it further says he'll
be helped by four companions referring
to the four sahabas the Rashid Abu Bakr
Omar us and Ali Allah be pleased with
them all and it says that he will be
helped by the deas the angels in the
battlefield and we know the Quran
mentions in Surah Al Imran chapter
number 3 verse number 123 to 125 as well
as in Surah anal chapter number 8 verse
number 8 and 9 that the Angels helped
mhammad sallah Ali wasallam in the
Battle of bad and because of them
muhamad sallam was Victorious this was
in brief talking about the kar which is
mentioned in Hindu scriptures for more
details on Muhammad sallallahu Ali
wasallam Hindu scriptures you can refer
to my video cassette on this topic which
give more details
on Muhammad sallallah alaihi wasallam in
the Hindu
scriptures let us discuss the prophecy
of prophet Muhammad peace be upon him in
the Pary scriptures